Deadpool - once again stars Ryan
Reynolds as Wade Wilson the Merc with
the mouth whoo this time around is
bringing together a team known as the
x-force to try to help save a mutant kid
who's in danger of being killed by the
time-traveling mutant cable played by
Josh Brolin because this is apparently
his year I'm a massive fan of the
Deadpool character as well as the first
film I thought that was a very
straightforward simple extremely
exciting hilarious subversive comic book
movie and one that I had been wanting to
see for a very long time but the
director of that film has left the
franchise and the second film is being
held by the man behind American blonde
and tons of incredible Hollywood stunts
for many years he's known for crafting
extremely great action scenes and
Deadpool 2 is filled with them this
movie is a blast to watch in regards to
action that's for sure in particular a
white-knuckle chase scene in this film
that rivals the highway chase that
started the first and as per usual with
the Deadpool character this film is very
very funny
tons of jokes not all of them land as
usual with a comedy but most of them do
because this character is so endearing
despite being so loudmouth and annoying
but this film actually does something I
didn't expect it definitely tries to
bring Deadpool down to earth a little
bit it explores more of Wade Wilson and
less of Deadpool we get some pretty
extended sequences where he's not in his
costume dealing with some issues that
happen and it definitely makes him a
more compelling character with a deeper
side to him but I suppose my biggest
issue with the film if I were to
pinpoint one it's that sometimes that
humanizing element with Wade Wilson
comes off as an attempt to give us an
excuse
to create the X force which will then
lead to more franchise possibilities
because in the first film one of the
things I loved about Deadpool was that
he was so against teaming up he was just
his own guy there was nobody else like
him he didn't want to start teams or you
know become part of the Avengers have
become part of x-men he just wanted to
do his own thing and in this film they
have to kind of tweak that a little bit
because they want to go forth with the
x-force possibilities and so
they are able to find compelling ways of
making Wade Wilson seem more like a
person and making him seem more open to
those possibilities but it sometimes
does come off as they're turning the
screws a little bit to try to serve the
franchise capabilities that Deadpool now
has considering how successful the first
one was but I have a feeling that most
people are going to look at the film
that way and they're probably just going
to enjoy seeing Deadpool team-up with
other people the way the x-force is
promoted in the trailers you just see
like shots of Terry Crews and domino I
did not expect what happens and I loved
it there is a sequence in this film that
is so out of left field I truly had no
idea was coming and I thought it was
extremely hilarious
this movie does a really good job of
subverting expectations well also being
a little bit of the same sometimes the
film can feel like leftovers from the
first it doesn't always feel like we're
seeing something particularly fresh or
new especially with the main plot
involving protecting a boy from a
futuristic killer we've seen that before
in Terminator 2 and so you know there
are aspects of the plot that felt a
little recycled brolin as cable is
incredible he's one of my favorite parts
of the film I wish there was more of him
for the first half but once he does show
up he adds so much but at the heart of
this movie they're trying to explore a
relationship between Wade Wilson and
this kid played by Julian Dennison who I
thought was excellent in hunt for the
wilderkin here he has a lot of
opportunities to really shine and
sometimes this relationship can be a
little confusing I feel like on second
viewing it's gonna be so much easier to
just sit back and enjoy and it'll
probably improve a little bit but on
first viewing it felt kind of hard to
keep up with because the kid changes his
mind way too much but those are the kind
of thoughts you're having as you're
watching the film and once you get to
the end and you kind of understand more
about his backstory then those problems
kind of just fade away so expect to
maybe be confused about his position the
things he's saying or doing a little bit
but it becomes more clear as the film
goes on and at the same time he's an
adolescent boy so obviously his emotions
are going to be going all over the place
especially once you uncover
is past and so it's not really an issue
in the long run for me it's just
something that I noticed while watching
it that was definitely improved towards
the end so the action sequences are
phenomenal it's a very funny movie it's
just that sometimes the emotional core
can be just a little Hollow especially
with a scene that occurs towards the end
that just didn't really land for me it
felt just a little too much I kept
waiting for Deadpool to make fun of it
but he didn't and so that means they
were actually really trying to go for it
and it just didn't quite work for me the
emotional side of the movie is there
it's just it wasn't earned as much as I
would have liked it to be all that being
said this film has the best end credits
sequence I have ever seen
stick around for that because it is
worth it Deadpool 2 is a very fun movie
I had a great time with it and I want to
see it again I have a feeling it will
improve on multiple viewings but it's
not quite as great as the first film to
me the first film just felt a little
more straightforward and more tight this
film has more that it's trying to do and
sometimes it can feel like it's going in
multiple directions and those directions
don't always come together but as a
Deadpool fan I'm satisfied I thought it
was a lot of fun and I'm excited to see
it again I'm gonna give Deadpool to a B
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I apologize that I wasn't able
to get this review up at the same time
everybody else was I need more time to
work on my reviews nowadays because of
my schooling and that's causing some
scheduling issues and making things a
lot more hectic than they were before
and so sorry for that but I'll do my
best to get the reviews out as soon as I
can in the future you guys are the best
and as always if you like this you can
click right here and get stuff mine eyes
[Music]
you